engine X is an open source web server
software used for reverse proxy load
balancing and caching it's important to
understand especially if you're a
back-end developer you'll learn all
about engine X in this crash course from
senior developer La harb Hello everybody
welcome back to the channel in this
video what we're going to do is we're
going to cover engine X in great great
detail now let's actually go ahead and
begin by discussing what exactly is
engine X and what its purpose is and I
think the best way to show this is to
show an example where engine X is being
used so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to go to my browser right over
here and I'm going to go to
airbnb.ca now as soon as I go to
airbnb.ca you can see that my browser is
served a bunch of different content you
can see there's content here we have
this huge image right over here we have
this image Etc Etc now the question is
is how did my browser get all of this
content well in order to understand this
we can actually dissect this by
inspecting it right click inspect and
then looking at the network tabs right
over here so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to refresh and as soon as I
refresh you can see here I get bombarded
with a bunch of different networks so
these are network requests that were
made from the browser to a particular
server in order to get content now I'm
going to go ahead and click on the very
first Network request just to get a
little bit more information about it so
you can see here this is the URL that
was made to a particular server you can
get a bunch of more information but I
want to go over here scroll down a
little bit and what I want to do is I
want to go to this server section right
over here so you can see here the server
is actually engine X so engine X was the
one that served us content served us
this web content to our browser and
that's why enginex is very typically
known as a web server it is a server
that is going to serve web content to
our browser now that's not particularly
accurate cuz it has another definition
we'll talk about that later but it is
typically used and treated as a web
server so again a server that is going
to serve us web content to our browser
now I hope that makes sense but if it
doesn't I actually have a bunch of
diagrams that I would like to show
you so let's actually go ahead and go
through this example but in diagram
format so over here let's say I am on my
computer and I go to
airbnb.ca now typically what we would
think would happen is we make a request
over the internet to a server that
Airbnb is hosting I'm pretty sure Airbnb
uses AWS so let's say there is a server
on AWS that it is hosting and once we
make a request it's going to process
that request and send back a response
for that web content whether it's the
image the content Etc now you might be
thinking where in the world does engine
X fit in here I don't see engine X at
all well right here there is no engine X
but this is typically not how web
content is served typically it is served
something like this so instead of when I
go to
airbnb.com instead of making a request
directly to the uh uh to the Airbnb
server I make a request to engine X an
engine X server so the the the the uh
browser makes the request to the engine
X server and then the engine X server
makes a request to the Airbnb server the
Airbnb server responds to the engine X
server gives in all the content and then
engine x what it does is it sends back
the content to the browser now if you're
familiar with infrastructure and
architecture this is actually known as a
reverse proxy again treated as a web
server but the technical term for this
is a reverse proxy now you might be
thinking why in the world do I even want
this middleman here this just seems like
a whole lot of more work uh why can't I
just make a request directly to the
Airbnb server well this wouldn't be a
bad idea if we uh weren't getting a lot
of traffic to our application however if
we get a lot of traffic what we need to
do is we need to somehow increase the
number of servers that we have inside of
our uh uh our AWS uh account now the
reason for this is because Airbnb is
very popular has millions of millions of
users using it all the time if you only
had one server then this over here is
going to get so many requests that it's
going to reach a bottleneck and
eventually the latency is going to be
extremely low so what we need to do is
we just need to increase the number of
servers that we have now by increasing
the number of servers this actually Pres
s another problem well now what we need
to do is somehow well go to This Server
one time go to This Server another time
go to This Server another time so how do
we do that well this is where engine X
comes into place so over here the client
only only sends the uh the request to
engine X we have one instance of engine
X right over here and enginex is
responsible for forward forwarding this
request to a available server now this
is actually known as a load balancer so
engine X can uh act as a load balancer
so for example right now we make a
request to engine X engine X makes a
request to This Server gets the response
sends it back maybe the next time we
make a request another person makes a
request it makes a request to engine X
see we're still just making a request to
engine X but then this time engine X is
making a request to this server and then
it's getting the response and sending it
back now the client doesn't have to do
all this it just makes a request to this
load balancer and then it's just going
to get the response and this is very
good for scaling your
application okay so I hope you can see
this is just one really really important
use case you can see engine X can act as
a load balancer now another uh very
important use case is encryption so if
you ever go to a website you can either
see that it is either http or
https so if it's https that means that
the server is encrypting the data that
is being sent and return so it's
encrypting and decrypting this data and
uh that's the way that we get https and
we have a secure server now this
actually presents a problem when we have
multiple servers because if we have
multiple servers we're going to have to
encrypt every single one well that's why
we would probably want to use engine X
in instead of encrypting every single uh
instead of having this encryption and
decryption process in every single
server you can just have it right over
here in engine X and then and then we
can make a request it can be encrypted
send it to the servers get it back
decrypt it back over here and you can
see that this is way easier to set up
https now there's a bunch of other
methods or B bunch of other good reasons
why you'd want to use engine X and a
reverse proxy in general but those were
the two most important you can actually
look up why you would want to use a
reverse proxy you can just search it up
and there's a bunch of different content
but I hope this diagram illustrates that
now with that being said let's just go
ahead and get started with actually
coding out engine X in this section of
the course what we're going to do is
install engine X on our local machine so
we can get started and work with it now
I'm going to show you how to install
engine X on a Mac however if you are on
a Windows device it is not that
difficult I will leave a link in the
description as to how to install it now
if you are on a Mac let's go ahead and
install it so in order to do this what
we're going to need to do is open up our
terminal and very simply just do Brew
install engine X now in order to do this
you're going to need to have home brew
installed which is the package manager
I'll have a link in the description as
to how to install this again relatively
simple now I already did this so you you
go ahead and do it if you haven't
already now what this is going to do is
it's going to create an engine X
directory inside of the user SL lo/ Etsy
file so over here we're going to have an
engine X directory and if you do an LS
and inspect what's inside it you can see
we have a bunch of different files and
folders so to open this up in vs code
I'm just going to do code dot let's go
over here and and right away you can see
we have again a servers directory and
then we also have a bunch of different
files now specifically what we're going
to be working on is just one file and
that is this file right over here the
engine x.com which is the configuration
file for configuring engine X the
reverse proxy so this is where we're
going to do a lot of the configuration
where it's going to reach out to a
particular server and then serve us our
web content so this is what we're we're
going to be editing and in the future
section I'm going to go ahead and just
completely remove everything and start
from scratch but for now what I want to
do is I want to start up engine X to
start up engine X all you have to do is
say engine X like so and then let's go
ahead over here to our browser and let's
go to Local Host 880 and right away you
can see that we get this file right over
here so what's happening is we're making
a request our browser once we go to to
Local Host 880 it's making a request to
engin x engin x is then going ahead and
serving this content and of course we
can always see this by looking at the
network tabs so let's go over here let's
do a quick refresh and then you can see
here that we're making this particular
request you can see that the server is
indeed n x okay so this is looking quite
good now let's go ahead and start
actually returning some other uh files
and folders and images that we want for
our
application now that we have installed
engine X and we are running it locally
on our machine let's just talk about
some of the important engine X
terminology so in order to do this let's
go to our engine x.com file and let's go
ahead and explore exactly what is going
on here now there's quite a bit and this
might be confusing at first but if you
look around you can see that there are
two distinct things that exist inside of
this file so the first thing that exists
is something that looks like a key value
pair so right over here we have the key
in this case the key is worker processes
and then the value is one you can see
here we also have another key include
then we have the value of mime. types
over here default type as the key and
then we have this value right over here
so you can see that we have a bunch of
these these things but we also have this
other thing right over here this events
block so this block of code and then
within it we have those key value pairs
so instead of referring to them as
things let's actually go ahead and
Define exactly what these are so this
right here these key value pairs they
are known as directives so over here we
have the key we have the value this
right here is a directive this right
here here is a directive this is a
directive this is a directive now these
blocks of code so with the curly braces
well these are known as the context and
within the context you can have
directives for that specific context now
right over here we have the HTTP context
and what that is going to do is Define
our HTTP server and then within this
HTTP context we have directives that are
going to Define it all right so that's
pretty much much all it is that we need
to know in terms of the definition let's
actually go ahead and just completely
remove everything right in here and
we're going to start from
scratch all right my good friends now
that we have that all set up let's talk
about exactly how we can start serving
content to our web page specifically
we're going to work on serving static
content and what I mean by Static
content are simple files like HTML files
CSS files and images to our web browser
so let's actually go ahead and go to our
terminal I'm going to move into my
desktop I'm going to make a new
directory so with mior I'm going to say
my site I'm going to move into my site
and then I'm going to say code dot to
open up a uh vs code instance so let's
go over here and I'm going to go ahead
and open that up and then right in here
I'm going to create an
index.html file file and I'm going to
add an HTML tag let me zoom in here HTML
tag and then I'm going to add a
body and then I'm going to add an H1
then in here I'm going to say hello my
friends I am served from engine X all
right so this is looking great so now
what I want to do is somehow configure
engine X to serve this
index.html file whenever I go to Local
Host 8080 so how are we going to do this
well of course what we need to do is we
need to Define some contacts as well as
directives now because what we're doing
is we're dealing with HTTP responses
what we need is we need an HTTP context
we also need an events context that
we're not going to use we just need to
Define it for engine X configuration to
work so right over here what we're going
to do right inside of the HTTP we're
going to Define another context and this
is going to be the server and then
inside of the server this is where we're
going to define a bunch of different
directives that are going to configure
this engine X server so the first thing
that we want to do is we want to have
the listen directive we want to say that
we want to listen on port
8080 now that next directive is going to
be the root directive and this is going
to be a file path that is going to
contain a bunch of different files that
we want to serve when we go to this port
right over here now this path is going
to be well this folder right over here
this my S sites folder so what we can
actually do here is we can go here copy
the path
and then we can say root is this path
and we can remove the
index.html and just have a semicolon so
we're saying once we go right over here
to this port I want to uh serve all the
files from this route now what it's
going to do is it's going to look for an
index.html and serve it once we hit this
path so that's pretty much all it is
that we need to do in order to well
serve this static HTML so let's go ahead
and Save that now if we go back to Local
Host 880 and we do a refresh you can see
that we're still getting this default so
it's not serving our HTML and that's
because what we need to do is we need to
reload engine x with this new
configuration this is relatively easy
thing to do you can go ahead and open up
any terminal I'm using the integrated vs
code terminal and I'm going to say
engine
x-s and then reload so that's pretty
much all it is that you need to do
and now if you click refresh you can see
that now engine X is serving this
wonderful uh uh beautifully designed uh
static HTML file so I hope this makes
sense we have these directives and then
right in the server we're saying hey we
want to listen on Local Host 880 and
this is what we want to serve so we this
is this is where the file that we want
to Ser that we want to serve lives
in this video what we're going to do is
learn exactly about mime types now to
explain what this is what I'm going to
do is I'm going to go over here to the
website and let's say I'm sick and tired
of this plain old website what I need
are some Styles so I'm going to go over
here I'm going to add a
styles.css file and then in here I want
to style the H1 I want it to have a
background color of pink I also want it
to have a color of aqua like so and then
over here what we're going to do is
we're going to rework this so we can
actually go ahead and use this style so
at the very top what I want to do is I
want to say Doc type
HTML and then over here inside of the
HTML tag I'm going to add a
head and then I'm going to add
meta and I'm over here you're going to
say charet is equal to
utf-8 Let's also add a title might as
well just saying my engine X
Project and then lastly what I'm going
to do is I'm going to add a link and
this is going to link the
styles.css all right so let's go ahead
and refresh and now if I go here you can
see that the Styles actually isn't being
applied now why is that is it not being
served by engine X well let's go ahead
and
inspect and you can see if we go over
here to the console you can see that
well it doesn't seem as though it is
served however uh if I go to the network
Tab and I were to
refresh let's go ahead and refresh this
after a few more reloading you can see
that the styles.css is actually served
to the web page so why do we not see the
Styles inside of this HTML file well the
reason for this and we can actually
explore this when we click on it let's
go ahead and click on the styles.css I'm
going to zoom in here and uh let's uh uh
let's just give us a little bit more
real estate actually we can just close
this that looks good and now if you go
scroll down over here you can see that
the content type is text- plane whereas
it should be text- CSS so that is the
issue that we're facing right now any
type of file is going to be relayed with
this content type and what we need to do
is we need to change it so right over
here what we can actually do inside of
the HTTP context we can Define all of
the different types so I'm going to say
something that is text. CSS is going to
have a CSS uh extension so it's going to
have CSS anything that is going to be uh
HTML well this is going to have an HTML
extension so now what I'm going to do is
I'm going to go ahead and reload this
and now if I were to refresh this and
click on the content type you can see
it's still text
plain uh let's just do a hard reload now
uh now you can see that it is indeed
text CSS so that's what it should have
been I just needed to do a hard reload
because the caching was uh was showing
that is text plain so hard reload is uh
command shift R and now you can see that
finally the the styles are being applied
because now we have the correct content
type now this right over here is good
the approach that we did but there's so
many different files out there we're
going to have to catch all of the files
manually and we're going to need to add
them inside of this types right over
here now luckily we actually do not have
to do this because engine X comes with
default mime types so right over here we
can actually click on the mime
types and let's go ahead over here and
you can see all of the different types
that we can have we can have gifs we can
have JPEG and these are just a bunch of
different configurations that we can add
so what we can do is we can actually
copy this this and paste it in here but
we can actually do one better instead
what we can do is just completely get
rid of this and use the include
directive I'm going to say I want to
include the mime types and this is just
going to includ include all of the
different types inside of this engine X
configuration so let's go over here I'm
going to go ahead and uh just reload the
engine X
server and of course we need a uh a
semicolon right over
here reload the engine X configuration
let's do a hard refresh and now you can
see that everything is working the exact
same way so that right there are mime
types in this section of the course what
we're going to do is we're going to
learn about the location block or the
location context now this is a very very
important Concept in enginex because it
allows us to specify certain end point
Point certain pages that we can hit and
then we can serve different types of
HTML elements so for example let's go to
my site and what I'm going to do is I'm
going to create a directory let's call
this fruits so let's say over here this
is a website that is going to list a
bunch of different food and then over
here inside of the
index.html I'm going to go ahead and
just copy everything that we have right
over here and we have an index.html
inside of this fruits directory
and let's just get rid of the Styles
here we don't need that and then over
here let's create a list item or a ul
and then An Li and then inside of the LI
let's say mango let's add another
Li let's say here
strawberry and then lastly I want
another
Ali and let's add another fruit
watermelon something like so so what we
want to do is when we hit to the slash
fruits directory we want to serve this
index.html and now we can do that with a
location context now this is going to
live inside of the server so over here
what we can do is we can say location
and this is going to take a second
argument and this is going to be the
path that we want to hit so I'm going to
say fruits so this is when we go to
Local Host 8080 SL fruits what we want
you to do is we want you to serve the
index.html inside of the fruits
directory so what we can actually do
here is very simply just grab this same
exact route and paste it in here now
what this is going to do is it's going
to specify is the root when we hit the
SL Roots directory as SL user La harb SL
desktop slm mysite you might be thinking
well is that going to serve this
index.html file and not this index.html
file well if that was it then yes it
would serve the uh this parent
index.html file but when we use location
what what's going to happen is it's also
going to grab this right over here the
SL fruits and add it in like so and
that's why we didn't specify uh uh uh
Slash fruits at the very end because
then what would what what would happen
is it would grab this right over here
and then append it like that so it' be
SL fruit SL fruits so I hope that is
nice and clear so let's go over here
let's go back to our
terminal and let's do a Reload so I'm
going to go here say engine X SL reload
and then over here let's get rid of this
for now we don't need that and now if we
go to slash fruits you can see that now
we are serving this
index.html how incredible is that now
let's say say what we want to do now is
we want to go to slash carbs for example
and right now of course we're getting a
404 but what I want to do is I want to
go to slash carbs and I want to get
these same uh uh fruits over here
because these are very carb heavy Foods
might as well reuse them for slash carbs
so how are we going to do that well you
might be thinking that we can just do
the exact same thing we can do slash
location and then over here we can say
carbs and then we can specify the root
over here now this is going to present
an issue because well what's going to
happen is it's going to go ahead and
append slash carbs right over here a not
slash fruit and as you can see we do not
have any carbs directory inside of our
application so instead what we're going
to do is we're going to somehow need to
specify hey I don't want to uh I don't
want to append this to the very end of
the rote and I want it to be slash
fruits so in cases like these instead of
using root what you would use is Alias
and so Alias is not going to append this
right over here into the very end so
right here what we can say is slash
fruits like so and then let's go ahead
and copy that open up the
terminal and let's go here
reload and now if I go to slash carbs
slash carbs like so you can see now
we're getting the exact same index.html
file so remember Ilias is not going to
append this path over here like root
would so anytime we use root you
actually have to make sure you have that
exact same directory inside of your
application whereas with ilas you do not
need to have a carbs
directory okay so this is looking really
really good this is incredible
uh but now what I want to do is I want
to add another directory let's add a
vegetables directory so this is a tough
word to spell so just make sure you have
it right it's uh v g and then tables
like so and let's say inside of this
directory we actually do not have um we
actually do not have an index. HTML file
instead what we have is let's say a uh
let's say a veggies. HTML file so it's
not index it's veggies. HTML I'm going
to go ahead and just copy this paste
that in there and let's go ahead and
name some vegetables uh
lettuce uh what are some other
vegetables let's just say
eggplants uh and then one more vegetable
onion okay so now what we want to do is
well we'll say when we go to uh when we
go to
Veges vegie tubles like so what we want
to do is we want well the specify root
because we have a vegetables
directory over here now do you think
that this is going to work so let's go
ahead and actually just give this a
quick little
test uh and then let's go here let's do
a quick little reload let's go to SL
vegetables SL
vegetables and then you can see we're
actually getting a 403 Forbidden so it's
not a 404 but it's a 403 because we
cannot find an index. HTML file in here
now we do not want to serve the
index.html instead what we want to serve
is the veggies.
HTML so in order to do this what we can
do is we can actually add another Di
directive right over here called Tri
files so by default it's going to look
for an
index.html however when we specify Tri
files we can say here Tri files and we
can specify a bunch of different uh a
bunch of different uh directories that
we want you to try so over here what
we're going to say is hey we want you to
look for
vegetables slash and then vegetables and
then over here we're going to say
veggies.
HTML so this is going to be from the uh
the root path so vegetable V HTML so
look for this file so if this file
exists then go ahead and uh use it so
use this file indeed now if this file
does not exist well we can also say here
is well use the um you can say use the
the
index.html so this is going to be this
file right over here right in uh the
default so that's going to say hello my
friends I am from engine X now if none
of these exist then what we want you to
do is just to just throw a 404 error and
so let's actually go ahead and give this
a try now so I'm going to say engine X
reload and now you can see now we have
lettuce eggplant and onion and so what
I'm going to do now is I'm going to
change this so let's say I changed this
to V's with a z so what it's going to do
is it's going to try to find this file
and if it can't find this file then it's
going to use the
index.html that exists in the rout so
now if I refresh you can see hello my
friends I am servering from engine X now
if it can't find neither of these it's
going to throw a 404 error so let me
just quickly go ahead and maybe just
rename this to let's say
Indie uh I'm going to rename them back
now you can see we're getting a 404
so that is the premise of try file so
let's go ahead and just rename all of
these back to veggies. HTML and HTML is
all good another thing that we can
actually do is we can actually add
regular Expressions to these location
context so over here let's say I have a
location and I have maybe a past count
and then and then over here I want a
specific number so what we can do here
is we can say from 0 to 9 you can add
any number and in order to actually
specify this we can say Tilda Star as a
regular expression now over here what we
can say is well I just want you to take
me to the root of the website and we can
just add a tri file right over here so
it just takes us to the
index.html so I'm going to say Tri file
index.html and if that doesn't exist
just throw a 404 so now what we what's
going to happen is anytime we go to SL
count4 SLC count5 SL count6 it's going
to redirect us to the index.html in The
Roots directory so let's go here and
let's just do a quick reload and if I
were to go to slash count sl5 you can
see now we are redirected back if I go
to two again we're redirect it back
because now we have this really awesome
regular Express
so I think that pretty much uh sums up
the location block the location context
pretty important to learn because it is
heavily used inside of engine X all
right everybody now that we have
explored the location block let's go
ahead and talk about some more advanced
concepts specifically redirects and
rewrites we're going to start with
redirects because they're relatively
simple so I'm going to go right over to
the the engine X configuration file and
let's say what I want to do is
whenever uh you go to slash I don't know
let's just say slash crops I want to
show the stuff that is inside of this
file right over here so one way of doing
that is of course adding another
location block but we've already done
this instead what I want to do is
whenever you go to SLC crops I want to
redirect you to slash fruits and then
show the HTML file in this root so how
are we going to do that well really
really simple actually this is going to
be another location block so I'm going
to say
location and then over here I'm going to
say that this location block is going to
be SLC crops and then I'm going to say
return so I'm going to go ahead and
return early this time I'm not going to
specify a root and I'm going to return a
307 so this is a uh HTTP code that is
going to redirect the user and we're
going to specify that we want to
redirect to slash fruits so let just go
ahead and uh copy this and let's go
ahead and reload our engine X
configuration and now what I'm going to
do is I am going to go to slash crops
and now you can see we get red directed
to slash fruits and if you look at the
URL I just went ahead and copied it you
can see that whenever I go to slash
crops it will always redirect me to
slash fruits what if however I don't
want this Behavior whenever I hit SLC
crops I wanted to stay at SLC crops but
forward me the HTML inside of that
location context inside of the fruits
location context how are we going to do
that let's actually look at another
example so right over here we have this
context right over here SLC count SL
number let's say I want to have another
location block or another endpoint that
is slash number and then slash whatever
the number is and I want to forward it
to this location context here however I
want the URL to stay like this and not
essentially change to slash count SL the
par number 0 to 9 so in that case what
we're going to do instead is a rewrite
rather than a redirect now for a rewrite
we do not have to specify the location
directive or the location context
instead we just have a rewrite directive
and then over here what we can say is
well I want number and then after the
number what we can do is we can just
wrap this in braces and over here we can
say uh uh the back bracket w+ and this
is just a variable over here and then
what we can say is we want to rewrite
this right over here so number slash
whatever to
count slash and then over here we can
say dollar sign one which is just going
to be the variable so dollar sign one so
this right over here is going to be this
right here and then we can just close it
off like so and that's all it is that we
really need to do so let's go ahead and
just do an engine X reload and now what
I'm going to do is I'm going to go to
number slash let's say three and you can
see number slash3 stays exactly the same
however we are uh essentially getting
redirected to this because what we're
doing is we're relaying this
index.html
file in this very last section let's
explore how we can configure engine X as
a load balancer so let's remember
exactly what I mean about a load
balancer when our application starts
getting a lot of users what we need to
do is scale our application and the best
way to scale our application is just to
build multiple servers within our
infrastructure now this obviously
presents an issue how is the client
going to make the request to the server
and which a server will it make the
request to so this can get really
complicated and that's why we have
enginex in the middle so instead of the
client worrying exactly where to make
the request to it's just going to make a
request straight to the internet and
that's going to be caught by engine X
and then it's engine X responsibility to
forward that request to any particular
server that it chooses and this is
typically done by a specific algorithm
now the most common algorithm is a round
robin algorithm where well the first
request comes in it just forwards it to
this server and then sends it right back
then the next request comes in well it
already sent it to this one then it's
going to send it to this one over here
this server and then forward the request
back and then it's going to go ahead and
send it to this and then send it and
forward the request back and it can just
keep going back and forth in a round
robin
approach okay so that is what we need to
configure now in order to do this what
we're going to need to do is actually
build a we're going to need to build
multiple servers and the best way to do
this is through Docker because Docker
allows us to build uh uh server
containers that are completely isolated
and we can actually spin up as much as
we want so that's what we are going to
do so we're going to build up a Docker
container right over here so if you're
unfamiliar with Docker and if you don't
have Docker installed that is a okay you
can just follow along but if you do I'll
have some resources below I also do have
a Docker crash course all right so what
I'm going to do here is I going to
create a brand new directory and I'm
going to call this just server and then
in here what I'm going to do is I'm
going to create an
index.js and then let's go to our
terminal and then I am going to do CD
and I'm going to move into that server
directory and I'm going to do mpm init
to initialize a node application so
let's go ahead and let's do n npm it-
y and then what I'm going to do is I'm
going to go over here and I'm going to
just say mpm install
Express because that's going to be my
server so let's go here and now I'm
going to say const Express is equal to
require
Express and then let's go ahead and do
const app is equal to express and then
over here I'm going to say app Dot and
let's just make a get request here and
then I'm going to
say that this is going to take in the
wreck and the res and it's going to just
respond
with I am a end point or something like
that something silly lastly what I want
to do is I want to app. listen so I'm
going to say listen on Port let's say
Port
7777 and then over here we can have a
call back we can say
console.log
listening
on Port
7777 so very very simple uh node
application so in order to actually
start this up what we can very simply do
is we can just say node index.js but a
better way to do this is to go over here
to our
scripts and then right here we can
say uh start at a new script and we can
say mpm Run start like so so let's just
say mpm Run start now and we should
start up the server let's give it some
time the server should start come on
come
on I was expecting the console log but
let's actually go ahead and see if this
server is running at this point uh let's
go
here and of course I'm checking NBA
scores so let's go here let's go to
Local Host 7777 I believe it
was and the server cannot be
reached oh okay of course so this should
be node index it shouldn't be mpm run
start this is my fault for rushing there
we go now listening listening on Port
777 there we go I am an endpoint so now
what we need to do is we need to
actually write a Docker file uh for this
application this is uh how we're going
to build an image and spin up multiple
containers of our image again again if
you're unfamiliar with this it's it's a
okay I'm actually just going to go ahead
and just research stalker file for
Express app just so we don't have to
build it out
ourselves so let's go here uh let's go
here let's
see um okay so this is looking pretty
good I'm going to go ahead and just copy
this and I am going to go over to here
and I'm going to say Docker file and I'm
going to paste in this Docker file
configuration so what is going on here
so let's change this to
7777 so the first thing that we're doing
is we're specifying a uh a an image a
base image so it's going to have the
basic
configuration uh with just the basics of
node and mpm and stuff like that then
what we're going to do is we're going to
specify a working directory and then
we're going to copy the package.json and
then we're going to do an mpm install to
install all the dependencies then we're
going to copy everything and then over
here we can either do node uh index.js
or we can do mpm Run start so let's go
ahead and do that
mpm
run start and that's pretty much all it
is that we need again if you're
interested in learning more about Docker
I do have a Docker crft course that
covers all this stuff in great detail
but now what I want to do is I want to
spin up let's say four different
containers uh that have this particular
application so let's go over here and
what we can do now is well we first need
to build this image this shouldn't be a
very long thing so let's move into the
server directory and I'm going to say
Docker build Dot and I'm going to give
it the tag name of let's say my server
something like that
so let's go ahead and uh wait for this
process now as this goes what you can
actually do if you have the uh Docker
utility tool so you can go over here to
Docker and I actually have a bunch of
other apps spinned up let me go ahead
and remove them CU they're all running
on the ports that I probably want to run
on so these are these are the containers
what we can do now is we can actually go
to the
image and we should see server
eventually pop up here uh so we got the
node app let's go back over here it's
it's taking its sweet time but it should
pop up right over
here let me zoom in I guess it's not
possible to zoom in So yeah so this is a
a tool that you get which is uh Docker
desktop in order to see all the images
that you have as well as all of the
different um uh uh containers that you
you are running as well as some other
really cool neat things now this is
going to take some time so I'm probably
just going to pause the video and I'll
meet you back so it seems like it's all
done now that we have built the image
what we want to do is run containers
based off that image so to do this what
we can do is we can do Docker run and
then over here I'm going to specify the
ports so remember this application was
running on Port 777 let's actually go
ahead and close it from here so what we
can do here is we can actually do port
mapping so I can say even though the
container is running on Port
7777 I can map it to Port 1111 on my
machine and this is how we can spin up
multiple instances of our app so over
here I'm going to say Port 1111 is going
to map Port 7777 inside of the container
I'm also going to run this in detach
mode and I'm going to specify the image
that uh we have just created which is my
server so let's go ahead and do that
and now what should happen if we go to
our tools and go to container we should
see we have a container running on Port
1111 and if we go on Local Host
1111 we should see I am an endpoint so
our server is running now we can do the
exact same
thing over here so I can say this time
2222 and then over here we can say 333 3
and then lastly I can say
4444 all right so this is looking quite
nice now what is it that we want to do
so now let's go back to our engine X
configuration and now what we want to do
is we want to add a load balancer so
whenever we hit Port Local Host 880 I
want to hit one of these servers and
then whenever I make another request I
want to hit the other server and then
the other server and the other server I
want to round robin across these four
different servers that I have created so
let's actually go right here to our uh
configuration and what we're going to do
here is we're going to remove the route
because once we hit the slash route so
just a local host 880 without any path
we want to serve our back end so over
here let's just go ahead and get rid of
this uh uh this uh uh root for now so
I'm going to go ahead and get rid of
that root actually no we're not you know
what we can actually leave the root as
is instead what we can do here is we can
say location Dash and then whenever we
hit this we're going to specify the
round robin now right after right uh
before the server context what we're
going to need to do is we're going to
need to specify our backend so I'm going
to say here upstream and then I'm going
to call this backend server we can call
this whatever it is that we want and
this is going to be a context and then
in here we can specify all of the
different backend URLs that we have so
well we have 1 one one we have uh 2222
we have 3 3 3 3 and we have 4 444 so
over here we can say 1
27.
0.0.1 and then I can say colon 1 1
1 and then I can do the exact same thing
so over
here let's just go ahead and say
2222 3 3 3 3 4
444 and then over here what we can very
simply do is say proxy pass and then I'm
going to specify
HTTP colon Das Dash and then this
backend server so this name is important
you have to go over here we're going to
say backend server Dash then we're going
to close it off with the semicolon and
so by default what this is going to do
is it's going to round robin anytime we
make a request to slash it's going to
round robin to This Server Then This
Server then this server and then this
server it's going to move back to this
server move back to this server etc etc
so that's pretty much all it is that
it's going to do so let's actually go
ahead and give this a quick go so I'm
going to do a engine X reload
configuration seems fine now when I hit
Local Host
8080 you can see here I had to just
quickly do a refresh you can see that it
hit I am an endpoint and then if I enter
it again it's not really visible here
maybe we should have added a log but it
is indeed round robing across all of the
different uh servers that we have up
again you're probably going to have to
just take my word for it but it is
indeed doing it all right so that pretty
much sums up this engine X course I hope
you guys enjoyed it and I'll see you in
the next one